không có bữa nằm bị phía không có phía là phùi
nếu mình chưa biết lập cơ của người đó là sao là gì
mình phải hết sức tận
mình gần mình ăn bồi rồi
quyết định một đêm là
nè lên sẽ khách lên thành quay
là mình đi lánh dài
những cái tội đầu tiên mình ngủ trong những cái
khuổ tròi mà dài mùi trẻ là em
cái cực tế sẽ hội
nó phút phà
còn những hộm lộm ui ăn trò
mỏ mẹ bế bết
cũng có lần là mình đi lánh dài
và mình đi ngâm điện bà
ở trong phục cộng
có một khách gọi mình vào đánh dài cho họ
thì mình đang lánh dài
thì có một thích nhiệp lánh dài khác
thì thì hình như thế có
là nhiệp ngờ mình chút
nó nghĩ không hiểu
hình như là rất mình vào trong cái lọc
ở đâu là mình
mầm giập ở trong này
vì thì rất là mẹ
cái cách truyến nó để bảo vệ mình
bỏ là chảy
cái truyến nhất của mình để là
phải miert mình còn gọi
còn phố
mà mình có thể chung vào đây
nè có ai đó hó
chú hình mình ai là mầng mình
thì cô gặp mình sau để xin lỗi vào đi tình đẹp nó
mình quên thì nó sẽ tẹp được cái sẹp tỏa
vào phố cast the first step
mấy nức